Most people assume,
or at the very least hope that their governments are doing the right thing,
but can you take this now down to the personal level and the community level,
you know,
from as simple as washing hands to just other techniques people should be doing
in their daily lives right now.
So the first messages wash your hands a lot and touch your face less.
That's the thing that everybody can do now because we're in a pandemic state,
we have to think about social distancing and that's going to be a little bit
different for every person, depending on what's essential to them.
And what's not essential.
Starting with people who are older or who have medical problems,
they need to start thinking about their interactions with other people and
trying to limit their risk, because that's what we're really worried about here.
That's what this is all designed to help them.
Because if they end up getting sick in large numbers,
we will crash our whole U S healthcare system because we don't have the capacity
to deal with that many sick people, such as what's going on in Italy.
Other individuals who are lower risk, you have to think about what you're doing,
how you can minimize your time,
minimize your contacts without completely destroying your quality of life.
You might there there's, you know,
there's some variation on what people can and can't do right now.
We're seeing governors, close bars and restaurants.
And I think that's something that you're going to see more of because there's
too much social interaction going on in those types of places.
And they end up being a nexus for the spread of the virus.
But I do think that just being common, common sense, you know,
if you're going to the gym, go at times where there's not, not peak hours,
maybe order out instead of take order takeout instead of sitting in a
restaurant,
maybe in mass gatherings and basically being banned everywhere because of their,
their risks. That's not an issue to think about, uh, any more, but it's,
it's that type of thing that you're going to have to do at least for a period of
two weeks,
maybe longer to see if we can actually blunt the response blunt the curve
basically, or flatten it out because we don't want to exceed hospital capacity.
So the,
the idea is let's slow the number of the rate of infection so that they're
coming at a slower clip to the hospital so that they don't get overwhelmed
because we're really nervous about that. That's the biggest,
that's the biggest in the linchpin in our response.
So I,
I know that you talked about the differences that Italy has just in terms of the
demographics and population. Um, but I hear a lot of people saying, Oh,
we're just two weeks behind Italy. Do you think that that's a fair estimation?
If you look at the numbers, we,
we have a case count around what Italy had two weeks before.
So I think it is something that people are saying with some evidence behind it.
I think we're going to start to know if we're going to follow this Italian type
of model or we're going to have more of a South Korean outbreak, but, uh,
it's increasingly looking like it might be a little bit of a hybrid between them
because we were not as quick with, uh,
testing mild cases and isolating them as South Korea was.
Yeah. Can you talk about flattening the curve?
That seems to be the phrase that everybody's talking about.
We're seeing a lot of images on Twitter.
Sure, sure. So what we're talking about here is the epidemic curve.
So think of it like a bell curve, you have a peak in cases, and then they go,
they peak and they come down. What we're trying.
And then me have a line here where hospital capacity is.
You want to keep your curve below hospital capacity,
even if it means you have the same amount of cases, but you flatten it out.
So you never exceed hospital. So that's what we're trying to do.
We know that we can't contain this virus,
but can we slow the accumulation of cases to a rate that's manageable by
hospitals? That's what flattening the curve is. So you don't have this big peak.
You kind of have a rolling peak. That's not as, not as huge of a spike.
And that's the,
that's kind of the strategy being pursued by many different countries. Now,
in order to preserve our hospitals.
There are guys like you turning for sensible information.
I see online.
That seems to be the number one thing just for the average person is we live in
a strange time where people don't trust our institutions the way they used to.
You know, there's always a lot of noise on social media. I mean,
w where are you getting actual information? Where,
where should we point people to besides, you know, interviews like this and,
and things like that?
Well, so obviously there, you know, if you're an infectious disease person,
you kind of have your own sources that might not be suitable for,
for people in the general public, but there are good sources.
The CDC is actually a very good site.
There's a lot of stuff on there that you can use.
That's actually vetted and there's guidance and lots of different types of all
types of different scenarios. You could imagine.
I think I would also make sure that people are looking at their local and state
health department websites, because if something happens to them,
it's going to be local.
You need to know what's going on locally and what the plant plans are there as
well. And then I would say for science stuff, I recommend stat news.
The most that news is owned by the Boston globe.
It's probably the best scientific reporting, uh, in the, in the world. Uh,
that's where I, I look at that every day.
And there's another group called Sid rap CID rap,
which is at the university of Minnesota. Uh,
that's the center for infectious disease research and policy.
They also put out very good, uh, news articles that are easily digestible, uh,
by the public and have a lot of really great factual information there.
Everyone we're obviously in some unchartered territory with coronavirus and our
plan here is to help you make as much sense of the situation in a not alarmist
fashion as possible.
If you're looking for reliable information from experts on the front lines of
the pandemic, check out our coronavirus playlist,
which we'll keep adding updates to right over here and to get notified of all
future videos, be sure to subscribe.